il faut revenir ici dans deux tours mais
c'est deux tours en pédalant debout je
ne m'assois pas sur la selle le BMX on
est toujours debout embarqué sur la
planète cyclisme au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce weekend
on fêté le vélo toutes ses formes très
bien un peu un peu compliqué on va
enfonce un peu de vélo mais sinon à part
ça c'était bien restez longtemps debout
sur ce type de vélo c'est dur c'est une
très bonne initiative et qu'il faut
continuer peut-être faire plus de
publicité du coup là-dessus pour les
familles et finalement peut-être inciter
aussi les parents parce que finalement
les enfants ils sont très favorables à
faire de du vélo la dernière étape du
Tour de France partira une fois de plus
des Yvelines le département organisait
donc à nouveau la fête du Tour cette
mobilité douce pour laquelle
actuellement nous faisons énormément de
travaux que ce soit le département le 50
ans en Yvelines ou la ville de Montigny
pour permettre aux gens demain de se
déplacer davantage à vélo c'est un enjeu
très fort donc il y a l'aspect sportif
et il y a l'aspect aussi formation et
sensibilisation démonstration atelier de
réparation baptême soirée festive le but
faire découvrir les différentes
disciplines du cyclisme qu'elle soit
olympique ou non souvent on a un format
chaud pour que les gens découvrent un
petit peu les démonstrations découvrent
les tricks parce que souvent les gens ne
connaissent pas le BMX flat et là vu
qu'on a un format duo aujourd'hui c'est
toujours un petit peu sympa de ce
challenger j'ai une discipline du BMX
qui se pratique uniquement au sol c'est
freestyle et il y a pas besoin de
mobiles
[Musique]
rendez-vous le 23 juillet prochain pour
assister au départ du peloton du Tour de
France avec comme objectif le maillot
jaune qui cette fois ne pendra pas au
bout d'un fil